hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
chapter five of book five of the
brothers karamazov has theodore
dostoevsky
putting a poem so to speak in the mouth
of
ivan karamazov a poem called the grand
inquisitor
and in it the grand inquisitor is
telling christ who has reappeared and
has been arrested
how christ made mistakes in
understanding and dealing with and
addressing human nature when christ
could have actually made all of humans
happy
he didn't do so instead he gave them
freedom and the grand inquisitor and his
colleagues are going to
improve upon the work of
god and in doing so they take
as their cues the three temptations of
christ
in the desert the first temptation
is that of bread and so
it's getting a little bit of a
reinterpretation
he says decide who was right
you were the one who questioned you then
the devil
recall the first question its meaning
though not literally was this
you want to go into the world and you
are going empty-handed with some promise
of freedom
which they human beings in their
simplicity and innate lawlessness
cannot even comprehend which they dread
and fear
but do you see these stones in this bare
scorching desert
turn these stones into bread and mankind
will run after you like sheep
grateful and obedient though eternally
trembling lest you withdraw your hand
and your loaves
cease for them so this is the temptation
and it's reworking it's no longer just
christ being tempted to turn
uh stones into bread so he can eat after
40 days of
fasting in the desert where he must have
been pretty hungry right
instead it's do this for humankind and
you could say well
wait a second in the the biblical
stories in the gospels
didn't he in fact like multiply the
loaves
and fishes and you could say yes that he
did he multiplied them he didn't just
simply
do hey presto turn this into that what
about the wine and the water and we can
quibble if we want about this dostoevsky
of course
knows the gospels just as well as
anybody else
it's not really about doing it in a
one-time
thing instead it would be doing it for
human beings
continually across the board
systematically
changing their their lives as a result
and so this is about satisfying
bodily needs primarily those
of hunger but we could read other things
in here as well
and christ rejects earthly bread
for freedom and what we can call
heavenly
bread that's that's a reference point in
here what is heavenly bread it doesn't
mean manna or anything like that
it means spiritual nourishment
and fulfillment and
you know the grand inquisitor says you
really made a mistake here
you did the wrong thing i understand why
you did it
at least i think i understand but you
didn't do
what you should he says had you accepted
the loaves
you would have answered the universal
and everlasting anguish of
human beings as an individual being
and of the whole of mankind together and
we're going to come to that in just a
bit
it could have given satisfaction to
human needs and thereby received
obedience this is a term that he uses
over
and over again the one who has the bread
will have obedience from the human
beings
who want the bread there's a point where
he says
you know they would have laid their
freedom at somebody's feet and said
better you enslave us
but feed us right so this is a
common human problem i mean many people
are
starving hungry even in the the
developed world
and you can say well what's the cause of
that and dostoevsky would say well i
mean there's a lot of causes could be
infertile soil could be
this and that but in first world
countries it's actually human freedom
that's the cause of it there are people
who
have enough and could give to somebody
else and don't do it
and then people starve and die in the
street
so this is something really worth
thinking about
he talks about human approaches to this
problem this ever-present problem
of need or desire for things that we
we need in order to satisfy ourselves
like bread
and he he says that if you give people
food
they will give up their freedom by
following and he's got a number of
places where he talks about this he says
here we go
you object man does not live by bread
alone but you do know that in the name
of this very earthly bread
the spirit of the earth will rise
against you and fight with you and
defeat you the spirit of the earth being
either
the devil or being just the way things
work
in this world and everyone will follow
him exclaiming who can compare to this
beast
for he has given us fire from heaven do
you know
centuries will path and mankind will
proclaim at the mouth of its wisdom and
science
there is no crime and therefore no sin
but only hungry
people that's another point there right
it's not just about
giving up freedom some people will say
listen human nature the way things work
we're animals
we need to eat and so if somebody is
depriving us or those who we care about
of food it's perfectly fine to go take
that food from them
it's fine to distribute it as a matter
of fact that would be doing something
good for the species
you could say not just for your own and
so
he goes on and he says feed them first
then ask virtue of them this is what
they will write on the banner they will
raise against
you meaning christ by which your temple
will be destroyed
and then he talks about a new tower of
babel
it being raised again in place of your
temple and he says
though like the former one this one will
not be completed either
you could avoided this new tower and
shorten people's suffering
by a thousand years you could have
cut out all of this crazy crappy time
of people starving to death while other
people
have you know more than they possibly
need seeing food
rotting when it could be going to feed
the many
who are hungry we should talk a little
bit about what the tower of babel means
for those who aren't familiar
with that metaphor so this comes out of
genesis
and the idea was that
a great tower would be raised that would
go
all the way to the heavens and god comes
along this is actually a really
interesting story it's very short
god comes along and says wow look at
this thing
who knows what these human beings are
going to try to do
if they pull this one off and what we
have here is a god who's really not that
omnipotent right or maybe he's just kind
of joking around we don't really know
how to interpret the story
and so he he destroys the tower and at
that time in the world
human beings all had one language so he
confuses the languages
so that they can't do that again and
confusing the languages
is in a way to confuse not just our
capacity to communicate
but our capacity to coordinate
to be on the same page so when it comes
to hunger
how do we deal with hunger well there's
lots of lots of plans
and they're very often compatible at
certain points and incompatible at other
points but people will raise
this new tower of babel which will be a
way
of providing for for everybody
and the grand inquisitors take over
while the entire
inquisition the entire church takes this
over he says
it is to us they will come suffering
after a thousand years of their tower
they will seek us out again
and they will find us and cry out feed
us for those who promised us fire from
heaven
did not give it and then we'll finish
building their tower
for not only he who feeds them will
finish it
uh only he who feeds them will finish it
and only we shall feed them in your name
for we shall lie that it's in your name
we're going to say well this is our
christian duty
we'll feed you and everybody will have
enough but it's not really going to be
about that it's not about christianity
it's really about finishing this tower
of babel
bringing humanity together in one
project
ending this sort of perennial conflict
between human beings over resources
and the inquisitors know some things
and this is what the grand inquisitor
tells christ he knows
the weakness of most human beings he
says listen
you came for the strong you came for
those who could live on heavenly bread
and not earthly bread he says you didn't
want to deprive
human beings of freedom uh what sort of
freedom is it you reasoned if obedience
is bought with loaves of bread and there
are some people
he thinks who are up to that challenge
and will be able to
you know stick with christ and and what
you might say
the project the plan and do so freely
give their love freely
but most human beings can't do that the
grand inquisitor says
most human beings he says are incapable
of being free because they're
feeble depraved non-entities rebels
this is an eternal weak eternally
depraved and eternally ignoble
human race and he says if in the name of
heavenly bread thousands and tens of
thousands follow you
what will become of the millions and
tens of thousands of millions of
creatures who will
not be strong enough to forego earthly
bread
for the sake of the heavenly don't do
you care about them at all
we care about them you don't seem to
care you only care about the
small number of people who
are going to be able to follow your path
we're actually looking out for the
masses we're the good guys here
he also says that they know
that freedom and earthly bread in plenty
for everyone are incompatible why
because human beings on the whole are
jerks there's always going to be some
idiot
who decides that they should spoil the
bread supply just out of rancor there's
always going to be some greedy person
hoarding flour hoarding bread hoarding
whatever it happens to be
gumming up the the methods of of not
just production
but distribution so that they can have
more than other people so you know if
you allow human beings to have freedom
you're not going to be able to feed
everybody and notice he doesn't just say
earthly bread
for everyone like we all get the same
crappy
you know little bread rash and with
pebbles in it he says earthly bread
in plenty we're never going to have a
society in which most people
can actually actually not just most all
people
can be properly fed and all their other
bodily needs can be taken care of
unless we find some way to get rid of
human freedom
or to use freedom in such a way that it
turns on
itself he also says and this is very
interesting and this is the lead into
the next temptation
that human beings and here we come back
to
you know what it is that would have been
revealed
he says you would have answered the
universal and everlasting anguish of
human beings as individual beings and
the whole of
humankind altogether namely before
whom should i bow down there is no more
ceaseless or tormenting care for the
human being
so long as they remain free then to find
someone to bow down to as soon as
possible so one way to know who to bow
down to is
who feeds you who takes care of you who
sustains you
and the grand inquisitor and his
colleagues
and their operation or organization
is answering that question we will feed
you
not that christ person over there who
we'll we'll talk about
and you know maybe worship in some sort
of way but it's going to be
us distributing the bread to you it's
going to be
us making sure that everyone gets their
fair share
it's going to be us give up your freedom
to us
and we will take care of your bodily
needs
and so what they're doing is creating a
new society
based on this understanding and they are
teaching this understanding to the many
to the crowd to the weak
telling them it's okay you can you can
give up your freedom
because we're going to take care of you
and they will do so
so this is what the first temptation
reveals to us this is a vital dimension
of the
society that the grand inquisitor is
envisioning and working towards
you